Speaker 1: If you want to hear an elected official
really relating to the plight of the average man
or woman in the United States, I can think of
no better example than radical and repugnant
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
whining that she only makes $174,000 as a member
of Congress and now she has to work most of the
year. If you can imagine, imagine that most of
the year she has to work and she's only getting
paid $174,000 while flying back and forth between
D.C. and her district on taxpayer funded airline
travel. I know this is sort of like when Trump
talks about his plane and it's super relatable
when he shows up in the middle of nowhere,
Oklahoma on his private plane and whines about how
he had to totally refurbish it in front of a crowd
that statistically wouldn't be able to meet a $400
unexpected expense without incurring debt of some
kind. Almost as unrelatable as Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE She appeared recently on the by the way,
she appeared on Glenn Greenwald's Rumble show,
which is sort of like a lead in to a completely
to another story altogether, which I don't have
time for today. On Glenn Greenwald's Rumble show.
Here is Marjorie Taylor GREENE bemoaning she's
miserable now that she's a member of Congress.
The salary is low and it's so much work for her.
Speaker 3: The nature of this job, it keeps
members of Congress and senators in Washington
so much of the time, too much of the time, to be
honest with you, that we don't get to go home and
spend more time with our families, our friends,
you know, all in our desk. Schachter
Maybe just be regular people.
Speaker 1: How relatable.
Speaker 3: Huh? Because this job is so.
Speaker 1: Factory workers all over
Georgia are sympathizing with us.
Speaker 3: Demanding it's turned
into practically you're around and.
Speaker 1: They expect me to
work almost the entire year.
Speaker 3: Plus in the House
of Representatives. We have
to run for Congress every two years. So you're
practically campaigning nearly the entire time.
Speaker 1: That's a fair criticism.
Speaker 3: That you're here serving
as a representative. So that's that's just a
couple of examples that I can give you that
I believe is a recipe for disaster. And that's
how people just fall into this social club. I
would call it a social club here in Washington,
D.C.. Now, for me, I have no interest in that.
I really don't. And I'll tell you why. Becoming
a member of Congress has made my life miserable.
Speaker 1: My life is also miserable because she's
in Congress. So it's not it's not that she didn't
only do this to herself, she did it to many of us.
Speaker 3: Before I got here. I've lost money
since I've gotten here. I have people come
up to me and say crazy things to me out of
the blue in public places that they believe
because they read it on the Internet or saw
it on some some news show.
Speaker 1: Right. That's
never happened to her out me.
Speaker 3: So it's not it's not a life
that I think is is like something that I enjoy.
Speaker 1: You can resign, Marjorie. You didn't
have to run for reelection, by the way.
Speaker 3: Oh, I enjoy it. But I'm
committed to this job because I believe in it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Not a single redeeming quality
about this woman now. Let's actually sort of,
like, be thorough here. How does Marjorie Taylor
GREENE $174,000 salary compare? You know, you can
you can look this stuff up. We're going to first
start with income percentile calculator. This
is for the United States. And if we type in her
salary, $174,000 for, I guess, what we will call
full time work, she is in the 92nd percentile,
92nd percentile, meaning that she makes more than
92% of Americans working full time. But 8% of
Americans make more than she does. And then if we
look at for her age, right, Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is 48 years old, so we can calculate this as well.
Hundred and $74,000 a year. Woops, that's 1.7
million. And she is also in the 92nd percentile
there. So, you know, it is not untrue that people
can make a lot more money in the private sector.
That that's absolutely true. Can Marjorie make
more money in the private sector? Because it's not
exactly clear to me what skills or competency she
has. Many people make more than $174,000. But
it's just not clear to me that Marjorie Taylor
GREENE would be one of those people. I don't
understand how poor white people in Georgia
love a woman who bemoans that she has to work
almost the entire year for only $174,000 a year.
That is really the greatest scam perpetrated by
the Republican Party on the American people and
their electorate. And this goes back to the Tea
Party of 2010. This goes back to economic policy
that would do nothing for the very people who say,
hey, you know what, let's vote for lower taxes for
the rich. Let's vote for people who will complain
about $174,000 salary. The only person may be more
repugnant than Marjorie Taylor. GREENE would be
her colleague, who I guess now she hates Lauren
Boebert. And I want to talk about Lauren Boebert
a little bit here before we go to our first break.